left-hander caleb smith his fourth start
since his return to the rotation on june
the first
yeah through a bold load of pitches last
time out on the 12th against the angels
went four and a third in that game
didn't pitch poorly gave up five hits
and four runs but to 103 pitches
to get into the fifth
[Applause]
well the slider left it middle middle
taylor missed it
and that's strikeout number one for
caleb smith
[Applause]
here's your double play ball ahmed for
one escobar
hey there caleb smith survives the two
bases on balls
servants coming up trevor bauer who
makes his
15th start of the season and is
in the building where it all began for
him at the major league level originally
drafted in the first round by the
diamondbacks
in 2011 third overall
sends one deep to center mookie betts
backing up still backing up
hats off the wall josh
earlhacks a laid off double
most guys have about 220 at this point
or more
and bauer got him to chase and he picks
up strikeout number one
got him on the outside corner at 96.
trevor bauer with strikeout number two
and he strands rojas
and to the second no score in arizona
his left knee just exploded
three torn ligaments wiped down his
entire season it was a huge loss for the
diamondbacks that here
caught looking at a slider and caleb
smith works a one two three
second d backs and the dodgers no score
from chase field
trevor comes into most outings really
having an ego about his fastball and
then doesn't move away from that until
it gets hit
this one here tonight he is gone right
from the get-go out of the bullpen to
some of his off-speed stuff a lot
earlier
and he gets him on three pitches good
morning good afternoon good night kelly
down
one two three go the diamondbacks and we
move to the third
[Applause]
got him with a fastball caleb smith
his second consecutive one two three
energy set down seven straight
d-backs and dodgers no scores
trevor has mostly worked the top of the
strike zone or outside to the righties
right there he carved that outside
corner with a two-seamer
rips this one down to third turner's got
it and there's one up
i would get my breaking stuff or another
pitch ready
for the second time around in the order
when the pitcher was up there
there's strikeout number four for bauer
as he caught smith just watching that
breaking ball
so maybe they should have waited until
the off-season to really put the new
rules in effect rojas on the move
he's in there well you wanted to run
more there you go
i like it third stolen base for josh
dave roberts is going to take a look at
it over there that first base dug out he
had a running start that time
power as i mentioned very slow to home
plate didn't really check josh rojas at
first base at all that time
martial rips it toward right field but
right there in the shift is taylor and
he throws him out
and tater and the dodgers take care of
business in the bottom of the third
inning
bull holes hit into a 6-4-3 to win the
first two on
the louds broken bat
and nick gabe goes top shelf to get that
one
aj rips it into left field a base hit
taylor will hold it third and the bases
are
full of dodgers first hit of the ball
game
for the dodgers comes off the bat of aj
pollock this is the moment this has
been the big bugaboo with caleb smith
the big inning bases loaded one out jam
hard to short ahmed for one escobar
caleb smith once again gets a double
play ball
and wiggles off the hook still no score
[Applause]
sports riders and the press and
broadcasters
as escobar goes down on strikes chasing
the high fastball
one gone that's five strikeouts for
bauer
here's carson kelly's strikeout victim
in the second inning
diamondbacks old for four tonight with
runners in scoring position
baseball is hitting well to left going
back aj
pollock and he's got room to make the
catch
side retired inning over we go to the
fifth
one out for gavin lux do it too
right there just dots that outside
corner nice pitch right there by caleb
smith
he was ahead in the count oh and two but
it took ten pitches to get the out
we saw some breaking balls even even in
the count last at back and now here
o2 count got there with two sliders
three sliders to put him away
six strikeouts now for bauer he's got
smith twice
and the diamondbacks with men on first
and second now
a little bit going with the heart of the
order coming up
and justin turner and foul ground will
have it diamondbacks now for six with
runners in scoring position still
scoreless as we go to the sixth
one two now there it is
came back with a good slider and gets
strikeout number five
twice in the ball game caleb has worked
himself into trouble
both times he got out of it with a
double play ball to win the inning
taylor still holding double play ball
here ahmed
escobar how do they roll one more
three double play balls behind caleb
smith each works
six scoreless as drupal cabrera is on
deck and then david peralta
three and two and walker strikes out
swing
the fastball was up and in and he tried
to get out of the way if it wasn't
it was more i got to get out of here and
the bat just happened to go through the
zone
spun him into the ground and then put
the sword away
2-2 got him swinging strikeout number
eight
changeup worked well certainly on a
night light tonight
makes sense for him to do it
steven souza jr and foul ground
he makes the catch susan with a
spectacular catch and foul ground
to retire nick ahmed and there are two
men away
boy what a play for steven souza jr
man to play will face steven souza jr
payoff pitch this ball's hammered to
left
deep and out of here a home run
stephen souza jr and the tie is broken
the dodgers strike in the eighth with a
solo home run
look at that energy from the veteran
and mookie hits a high fly ball to
center indeed
going back is martay he makes the catch
lux will tag and score milky drives in a
run
a buck a buck by creighton
and burns will come in to score it's
three nothing
can you imagine what's going through the
diamondbacks minds now with the losing
streak they're on and
giving up a run with a ball so many
dodger fans
and they're going to get rewarded ground
ball and
turner throws him out of the dodgers win
they take game one
kenley janssen his 17th save